we are experiencing a truly global
pandemic since the first coronavirus
case was reported to the World Health
Organization in December 2019 the virus
has reached almost every country of the
world its rapid spread has already had
profound health social and economic
impacts globally it has caused
disruption to people communities
businesses health systems and economies
and things are likely to get worse
before they get better
we will only win this battle with a
coordinated global response and
therefore we need to support our
partners Africa could experience the
same problems that we are facing in
Europe in a matter of weeks they need
our help to slow down the spread of the
virus as we needed help in this crisis
it is in our interest to ensure that the
fight is successful worldwide and this
is why the European Union is securing
more than 15 billion euros to help our
partners worldwide to fight coronavirus
and more money will come from our
national governments in a true Team
Europe spirit this could help cover
immediate needs in the health sector and
it should also support the economy in
these countries to keep people in jobs
the European Union stands ready to
coordinate a strong international
response to the pandemic we can defeat
this virus by standing united and
working together